[Music]
hi welcome to another cold fusion video
in the consumer-driven landscape of our
modern world the boundaries of
individual business sectors are becoming
increasingly blurry
some examples are understandable like
the hardware manufacturer IBM shifting
to investing in software or Lego
infiltrating the film and video game
Market but others are a little harder to
comprehend some companies have realized
that one of the best ways to make money
is to be in the business of money that
is the financial sector
in recent times highly unconventional
players have entered the money game
apple is one with their credit card but
Starbucks is another
founded in 1971. Starbucks is the most
famous name in Cafe beverages
but since then they've managed to use
customer funds to launch a clever
investment scheme
investing customer money without their
knowledge or even providing any returns
to said customers sounds like something
that should be illegal but if it's done
in the way that Starbucks has done it
it's very much legal
coffee shop on the outside and a
financial institution behind the scenes
it's so bizarre that it deserves a
deeper look in this episode we'll take a
look at their business model dissect the
mechanics behind its quasi banking
operations and we'll also see how it
deferred from the conventional banking
system
TV
the key to this clever plan is the my
Starbucks rewards system established in
2009 on the surface it's a simple
concept
Starbucks offers a mobile app where you
can store value in your Starbucks
account you load up on funds using your
credit or debit card and Starbucks
instantly receives the cash
meanwhile for the customer they earned a
digital currency called Stars which
accumulates with every purchase
eventually these Stars can be exchanged
for food drinks or other merchandise for
example after 10 Stars you get a free
drink and this is the incentive to get
customers in who doesn't like free stuff
so far it resembles a reasonably
straightforward reward system only with
a few extra steps but there are some
clever tactics taking place in the fine
print
while it is marketed as a digital
version of a punch card it's actually a
very clever way for Starbucks to invest
your money without you even noticing
Starbucks essentially receives an
interest-free loan from its vast
clientele every time they load money
into the reward system
and while you wait to purchase your next
Coffee Starbucks is busy earning
interest on your hard-earned money when
customers upload their funds to their
Starbucks card the company invests this
money in short term low-risk Ventures
the return is about 0.05 percent but the
sheer scale of the customer base means
that this Arrangement can be very
lucrative
there are 29 million Starbucks reward
members around the world some estimates
say that upwards of 10 billion dollars a
year comes through the Loyalty program
the value of the system is so Grand and
so valuable that if Starbucks was a
Traditional Bank it would rank in the
top two percent of U.S banks by deposit
size some of these funds deposited by
customers may not ever be spent
a 2018 estimate deduces that the company
earned 155 million simply from customers
who forgot about their cards
of course the company Isn't So Brazen
about its inadvertent banking operations
the system is skillfully obscured behind
a curtain of customer service and
convenience the customers feel satisfied
rewarded and none the wiser
on the surface the reward system seems
to be a clear win-win situation but
there is a bit of a gray area
when it's broken down to its Basics the
customers who leave their money in their
Starbucks rewards account are
essentially giving the company a free
loan that can be used to finance their
business operations
while it's not technically illegal it
does feel morally ambiguous almost like
the customers are getting the short end
of the deal
but people may argue that it's not their
life savings in the account and the
customers are getting free items out of
it so who really cares what consumer
Watchdogs do they note that although the
Starbucks model offers convenience it
might also encourage increased spending
they state that the psychology of
pre-loaded cards often leads to
Consumers spending more than they
otherwise would but from a pure business
perspective Starbucks has virtually
found a way to get free money and after
such success there's bound to be other
unrelated companies that are getting in
the business of money and that's what's
happening
everyone from Amazon and apple to
Walmart Target and Costco are following
suit
these companies have two things going
for them a strong established consumer
customer base and a strong brand
identity it's a potent combination where
they can mix primary goods and services
with financial services
combined with consumer convenience and
benefits the customers are bound to eat
it up
Apple entered Finance with Apple pay and
partnered with Goldman Sachs to launch
the Apple card an exclusive credit card
to their customers
Walmart launched the Walmart Money Card
a reloadable prepaid debit card as well
as Walmart to Walmart a peer-to-peer
money transfer service
despite these Financial Services these
companies unlike Banks face less
stringent regulations but this may soon
change at least a little bit
[Music]
government bodies are starting to notice
the trend of financial services coming
from seemingly random companies the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau is
leading the charge in the United States
they've proposed new rules requiring
companies offering certain financial
services including payment processing
and money transfer to register and
comply with user protection laws also
some states like New York are pushing
these companies to obtain a license for
providing such services
and it's not just the United States
that's taking notice globally countries
are recognizing the implications of this
hybrid model in the European Union new
rules are proposed requiring companies
offering specific Financial Services to
be licensed by the European Central Bank
the United Kingdom now necessitates such
businesses to register with the
financial conduct Authority
and in Australia they must obtain a
license from the Australian Securities
and Investments Commission
the effectiveness of these efforts
remains to be seen
as the boundaries of traditional
business sectors blur an error where
something as simple as a coffee shop
Rewards program can morph into
interest-free financial services without
customers ever noticing is pretty
peculiar
it is strange that a coffee Corporation
is acting like a bank without
regulations
although now under increased scrutiny
from authorities as long as nothing goes
wrong Starbucks isn't going to be on the
radar
but what do you guys think do you think
Starbucks should be more transparent in
what they're doing with consumer funds
do laws need to be changed or do you
think what they're doing is absolutely
fine as long as the customers are happy
it's an interesting murky gray area so
I'm interested to see what you guys have
to say in the comments just some
housekeeping before I go I've
collaborated with the Australian
broadcasting corporations channel for a
three-part series on AI the first
episode is going to be released within
24 hours so I'll leave a link to that
below thanks in advance to those who
have given it a watch okay so that's
about it from me thanks for watching my
name is and you're often watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next episode cheers guys
have a good one
cold fusion it's me thinking
[Music]